[Music]
so what is the multi-bear the multiverse
is the idea that it might be that our
universe isn't the only one that there
might be more universes beyond our own
beyond the boundaries of our own and
some people are even saying there might
be an infinite number of universes
beyond our own and why is this seeing
this sort of a problem all that responds
religion and science yeah so the reason
is that the multiverse idea has been
around for a long time I mean in in
Western philosophy it actually has about
a 2500 year history but it's come really
resurging back in the last couple of
decades
partly because physicists are looking
for an answer to why the university was
so finely tuned why it seems like all of
the constants of nature are precisely
set so that the universe can can emerge
can sustain life things like that and
the danger for physics is that if you
say that the universe seems really well
tuned for life that the theologians can
rush in and say aha God did that
fine-tuning right God is a kind of
cosmic mix maker who's like setting this
amount of gravity and this amount of
dark energy and this amount of electrons
right and so a rival explanation to God
is no no actually they're an infinite
number of universes that take on all
sorts of different configurations over
infinite time every once in a while one
comes along that happens to work when we
seem to be in one of those universes
that works yeah could that argument
still work with a god thing absolutely
this is the thing about theology right
it's remarkably resilient right a
theologian can always say right fine
there's a multiverse good God created
the multiverse and then the multiverse
created the universe so it's not
actually any kind of argument the
multiverse isn't any argument against
the existence of God sometimes
physicists think it is it's not it just
sort of takes some of his jobs away but
it's not it doesn't disprove anything so
I actually think that it's kind of
uninteresting to be stuck in this
back-and-forth over whether or not God
exists right with respect to the
multiverse I think the more interesting
question is what kinds of new stories
are we getting from these multiverse
cosmologies the new stories about where
we come from where we're headed what the
universe is like these are all questions
that myths used to
and answer for us in of any society
other than our own right now this would
be the function of myths physics is
doing it for us now so I like to look at
those stories and see what kinds of
values they're encoding what they're
telling us about ourselves whether we
like them or not right are they are they
telling us good helpful things yeah
so what awesome of these news stories
that they're telling us right so I mean
there there are tons of them if you ask
you know most theoretical physicists
I'll say right well there's only one
respectable one
the respectable one is that there's this
sort of primordial sea of inflationary
energy inflationary energies pushes
space out really really super fast and
this primordial sea races and races and
races outward and every once in a while
that energy kind of turns off and allows
little pockets of stable space-time to
form and those are universes so you get
these universes nucleating out of this
sort of primordial sea like sort of
pockets of air in Swiss cheese or
something like that so University
University University universe this is
called eternal inflation and the idea is
that our universe is one of just these
bubbles in this eternal sea of inflating
sort of hyper space-time that's one of
them there are other theories that argue
that every time a massive massive star
collapses and forms a black hole you get
so that you've probably seen drawings
right a spacetime kind of going like
this you get an infinite amount of stuff
in in zeroes but you have stuff crammed
into no space you've got a sort of point
of infinite density that point is called
a singularity physicists also talk about
singularities as or at the singularity
as having been what the Big Bang was
write a bunch of stuff crammed into a
point of no size so the idea is that
every time a black hole forms you're
actually producing a new universe on the
other side of the black hole so we may
have write hundreds of millions of black
holes in our sort of visible universe
and each of them the idea is would have
potentially a universe inside it and
conversely we're sitting on the inside
of somebody else's black hole all right
and that universe that's another idea an
idea that people love to ridicule is the
idea that our universe
all sitting on a 3 plus 1 dimensional
membrane and that that membrane has like
a partner universe which is also a 3
plus 1 dimension and they're sort of
hovering near each other separated by
this fourth dimension of space that
nobody can see but it's like right there
so this other universe would be like
right here just closer than anything to
us but we just can't cross the gap to
that other universe then every like
couple trillion years or so these two
membranes smash together that's the Big
Bang the universe is destroyed recreated
all the time and and we've got this kind
of cymbal crashing that makes a nun
makes the universe these are some ideas
right I find this fascinating right why
not look at these new stories and and
ask what it is they're telling us so
then how do you move from this like
highly scientific realm of these
different theories to then looking at
how what this means for our values or so
in the way that myths used to do
yeah well so clearly these stories are
all trying I mean they have lots of
differences among them right so we could
start looking at what those differences
are so the black hole guys are really
excited that they have what they call an
evolutionary mechanism that if a new
universe is being formed from say a
parent universe it retains many of those
characteristics of the old universe but
then sort of tweaks them so it's
basically evolution that's driving the
formation of universes so they're very
excited about evolution the membranes
smashing together guys are very excited
about numerical simplicity and elegance
they're very upset the idea of like
infinite numbers of universes being
spawned all over the place no no no we
need we need simplicity we need just two
of them just infinite recycling they're
recyclers they're so you can see you can
you can do that work I've seen what the
different values are among the different
physicists were setting forth these very
different stories but certainly what all
of them are trying to do is to account
for the emergence of the universe the
sustenance of the universe the
governance of the universe and the
ultimate destruction of the universe
without any kind of transcendent
principle without any sort of divine
figures and figure outside the universe
that's like regulating the whole thing
but it's not to say there's no
regulation there are regulating forces
inside the universe so usually you get
gravity and the cosmological constant or
dark energy kind of working with and
against each other to produce and to
sustain the universe these I'd like to
say we can look at as a sort of new
divinities or new heroes right who are
who are sort of making and shaping the
universe we get these sort of new mythic
figures who are emerging and they're not
again outside the universe they're
inside the universe so one thing these
stories are telling us is that we're not
so much abandoning the idea of the Gause
we're just trying to pull them like all
the way into the universe and see how
they're functioning through the natural
world itself I think it tells us a
little bit about a kind of collective
desire to see
the operations that we would
traditionally have called sacred in the
natural world itself
see how the natural world itself is
doing that work of universe making so do
you argue that there is a transcendent
figure no no no I don't argue there
isn't I don't argue there is I don't
think it's a game anybody can win if it
were possible to prove the existence of
God or if it were possible to disprove
the existence of God meaning a transfer
transcendent sort of humanoid figure as
if it were possible to prove the
existence of that guy or disprove the
existence of it somebody would have done
it by now right
like somebody would have come up with a
decent explanation it's been thousands
of years of attempts to prove to
disprove it like those were really smart
people it's not possible right you can
always make arguments on one side or the
other so I don't try to do that at all
what I want to ask instead is insofar as
the word God has traditionally encoded
our deepest values so traditionally
think for monotheistic societies what we
mean by God is a single male
anthropomorphic very powerful force
disembodied right that tells us that
what the West's values are are
singularity oneness maleness
disembodiment humanoid nests right it
just reflects our own values at us so if
traditionally God has encoded our most
powerful values what I want to ask
instead is how can we think about God
differently right how can we how can we
look at the values that we have that I
think are beginning particularly in any
kind of culture that's beginning to
value a new the world that were part of
the ecological set of systems that were
part of if our values are tending more
toward things like relation and
mutuality and the sort of participation
of all creatures rather than just the
dominance of humans
how would we have to change what our
understanding of what God looks like in
order to
values what kinds of gods do we want I
mean there are all kinds of societies
all over the place to sort of make and
ditch gods depending on how useful they
are we could do that too we could be
like all right what are useful gods look
like so I I think I'm much more
pragmatic
I think approach to it than any kind of
ontological approach I'm not trying to
argue there is or isn't a god I want to
say like what would it mean to think
about God productively and hopefully and
ethically and do you think that there is
that need for divinity no no see like
could give them fill these oh sure I you
know I think I think that uh no nobody
needs needs divinity for anything real I
mean well no some people do I've got a
friend he's a former Jesuit priest and
somebody asked him could you marry my
husband and me we're hoping to get
married but could you could you do it
without God and he was like - I can't
open the refrigerator without God but of
course I can't marry you with it so
right for some people that's absolutely
not an option right some people
absolutely orient their lives around
their understanding of what God is
whether that's the earth whether that's
a father in the sky whether that's
totally fine not a problem
but I don't think that some sort of
notion of God whatever it is is
necessary for example to lead an ethical
life right I don't think that it's
necessary to lead a meaningful life I
don't people can lead perfectly ethical
and meaningful lives as atheists they do
it's just that I find as somebody who
has traditionally studied religion that
often people who think of themselves as
atheists what they really just mean is I
don't like the idea of an eternal dude
in the sky standing over us and giving
us rules and I want to say like you know
what actually most people who believe in
God don't either
most people don't like that idea you may
not have to ditch completely the concept
of divinity in order to in order to
criticize the the sort of dangerous
position of that kind of that kind of
deity you can give up that kind of deity
and still have other ways of thinking
about divinity do we have to have them
absolutely not but I do think that the
particularly and this is what I've been
working on recently the Natural Sciences
and the Social Sciences are producing
these sort of unint
tensional theologies by ascribing again
to the natural world all of the
functions that we used to ascribe to
divinity so they think they're atheistic
I'm actually arguing they're kind of
pantheous that great that the divinity
is sort of C fused throughout the
natural world itself is that an
interesting move to make I'm not sure I
think right I think it's fun but I'm
certainly not out there to convince any
atheist but he's actually not an atheist
and how has that been taken by a
physicist like social scientists that
were working on such things do they
recognize in your work other than
divinity might exist in their own work
or is there been some opponents you know
some people actually find it charming
all right some people will be like
really am I am I like a modern-day myth
maker and my a modern-day healer and
that's fascinating as long as I'm not
trying to say that really they need
Jesus or something like that they're
totally fine with it
other people will say that it's just
unnecessary right but it's it's
unnecessary to add the concept of
divinity to the concept of the natural
world if you've got a natural world self
sufficient that's Auto creative that
works that we're all the parts are
working in different kinds of
collaborations to make what emerges
emerge you don't need to like add
divinity on to that atheism kind of
functions just just fine on its own
perfectly fine point to make I think
there's something to be said though for
working on the concept of God the
theorist hortense Spillers says that our
concepts do violence in the world right
our concepts like do work of
establishing some people as more
important than other people some species
is more important than other people i
really worrying about the concept of god
i really worry about it I worry about
the work that it does I worry about the
way that it still seems to establish
humans as superior to every other
species I worry about the way that it
still seems to establish men as more
important than women and like gendered
others I worry about the way that
because of Europe's traditional
alignment with that particular
monotheistic God it tends to establish
the supremacy of Europe and by extension
America
or every other region of the world so I
worry that if we don't do work on that
concept of God we just leave it there
intact as grounding all of these
hierarchies and then we can say oh but
it doesn't exist right that God doesn't
exist but that doesn't get rid of all of
those conceptual adherence --is that
keep those dualities in those
hierarchies in place I think there's
something to be said for like working on
the concept itself to say you know what
divinity does not mean omnipotence
doesn't mean you can just go in and do
whatever you want it means a kind of
relational negotiating power because
this is the way that we see that nature
works right nature doesn't just so
destroy everything and then recreate
stephane new nature works with what it
has with all sorts you know bacteria and
ants and mushrooms and trees all kind of
doing their part to make a forest of
forest
that I think is a more productive way of
thinking about divinity than a dude in
the sky and again I think if we leave it
to particularly conservative monotheists
to define what God means and the rest of
us just sort of sneak off into atheism
they've got God right they've got our
most powerful concept and I'd rather I'd
rather do work on that concept and is it
possible than to have a form of like
theism that isn't that sort of dude in
the sky in a way that it's like someone
that is higher than humans and that is
controlling controlling us does
pantheism sort of how can you radically
break that away yeah from like an idea
of divinity yeah
so the so the idea of pantheism would be
something like and I say would be
because it's not clear to me that we've
got a decent pantheism at the moment and
so I'm trying to figure out how to kind
of stitch it together and what it might
look like but the idea pantheism would
be that what we mean by God is the
natural world itself and by natural I
mean also the cultural world
technologies right every the world
around is the material world around us
there's also a world of ideas that stuff
is got how can we get away with calling
it God because what we mean by God is
the source of all things the life in all
things the end of all things why not
just say like that's that's what we mean
by the universe it's what gives us life
it's what right sustains us it's what
swallows us back and makes us into
something else by recombining our atoms
right so pantheism would mean something
like what we mean by God is the universe
itself so then we want to ask well like
how does the universe work and how does
how does how does the world work and we
can think about it on a small scale
about the earth or like a patch of
forest right how does the natural world
work to get stuff done and really the
agents of doing stuff in the universe
are not human beings
it's like bacteria right bacteria are
amazing creators well what I mean if we
like thought for a little while about
the creative work the bacteria it like a
bacterial theology right about these
like microscopic agents as the the
engines of life as the engines of
newness as the engines of what wouldn't
mean to think about rather than you know
consciousness or rationality as being
some divine principle you just usually
what we you know this characteristic we
ascribe to God
what about like gravity or magnetism
it's amazingly powerful forces that hold
things together that drive things apart
they get things like start somewhere
else start from some different place in
the universe that does creative work and
build your model of divinity there and I
almost think you could start from kind
of anywhere like a mustard seed or an
acorn or any right I think that kind of
pantheism would encourage us to look all
over the place and see how and where we
see like newness creativity productivity
at work
and has pantheism had a history what is
the history of pumpkin it's a really
hilarious history pantheism doesn't have
a great history it was coined as a term
at the outset of the 18th century it was
coined it's just like a nasty word a
like a bad thing to call dopey
philosopher the dopey philosopher in
question was a man named Burke Spinoza
who died toward the end middle end of
the 17th century and he had this idea
that he was he used the term God or
nature Deus si vain at Torah God or
nature and he sets forth this idea he
gets excommunicated from his Jewish
community and Amsterdam and for hundreds
of years afterwards in order to gain a
university professor ship in Germany for
example you had to take a pledge against
Spinoza he had to promise that you did
not affirm this so the position known as
pantheism again was was just like a
nasty name like a bad thing to call a
terrible person it's got a bit of a
resurgence in sort of 18th and 19th
century German idealism but most of
those German guys who take it up end up
then making fun of it when they get
older and kind of ridiculing it and
converting to a more orthodox form of
Christianity there's so again there's
not a great history of pantheism I think
you can see it kind of subtly at work in
say some of the German poets some the
English poets even some the American
transcendentalists but folks don't tend
to sort of take up the cause of like a
banner of pantheism so again part of the
work that I'm trying to do now is to
kind of stitch it together to like find
some friends to cobble it together
William James who's an American
philosopher pragmatist and psychologist
in the beginning of the 20th century
begins to say you know what it looks
like pantheism is the only viable option
for us these days like we can't believe
in this humanoid father-god anymore
we're probably gonna have to be
pantheists he's like but I'm not really
quite sure what this means so he starts
getting getting
about it but he doesn't quite set it
forth so that's what this work is trying
to do and do you feel like this would
have would it have radicals of political
ramifications
I my certainly my hope would be that it
could have radical ecological
ramifications the there's a historian of
ideas Lynne white who argued toward the
late 1960s he had he wrote a piece
called the historical roots of our
ecological crisis and what he was saying
was that the problem with ecology dates
back to the overcoming of paganism by
monotheism as you know in a pagan world
if the rocks are alive if the trees are
alive if the rivers have personalities
you can't just take them right you can't
just cut the trees down with impunity if
they have at their spirits if they're
living things you can't just remove
mountain tops if the mountain is a
sacred whipping being you have to at
least ask a river before you pollute it
right but he says that the problem with
the triumph of monotheism is that what
monotheism does is it reserves all
agency and all life for conscious beings
God and then humans who are in made in
God's image everything else is just dead
matter
animals and just use them with impunity
Rock server Street who cares right
so I'd like to think about if like if we
are thinking about rocks rivers trees
bacteria mushrooms as animate as getting
stuff done as in some way having agency
and even maybe personality which is what
a lot of Animists teach us that they
have personalities
I think I'm a real a lot harder to say
frack the earth for natural gas if that
earth were a living animate thing and
perhaps even sharing in what we think of
as divine so that's that's kind of the
hope the hope is to reanimate the
landscape I'm not the first person to do
this there are right new materialist
philosophers who were doing this
constantly who are sort of cobbling
together different ontology to see the
way that we can think of even like lead
and
steel as animate and certainly that what
we call the landscape as animate
what I'm trying to argue is that we can
use this work to start also tearing down
the concept of divinity is again
enshrining the importance of humanity
and sort of human comfort over
everything else and would you go as far
as seeing consciousness and in all
beings right so here's the thing yeah I
I guess I could say yes but then I get
worried about consciousness because
consciousness is the thing that we have
is that the the power the faculty that
we've traditionally reserved for human
beings right so I can see the sort of
generosity and saying look not only are
dolphins and dogs and whales conscious
but also rocks and rivers and trees are
conscious particles are conscious quarks
are conscious things like that I worry a
little bit about the way that that kind
of remakes the whole universe and the
image of the human so I'd like to talk I
guess a little more about them having
like personality or agency which or our
anima see which feels a little less like
it's taking the stuff that it's supposed
to distinguish us and then seeing
ourselves everywhere in the universe but
sure I you know I that's the position
known as Pan psychism right the idea
that everything down to the level of the
quantum has a kind of consciousness or
proto consciousness yeah I affirm the
pants like it's sort of pants psychic
viewpoint as as helpful and as useful I
guess I just I just worry that it then
ends up re-establishing a kind of chain
of being where photons and electrons
have a kind of proto like primitive
consciousness and then bacteria have
like a little more consciousness and
then you know a little and then you know
work your way up and you work your way
up and you're right and finally humans
have like serious consciousness where
you get that same establishment of that
hierarchy of being if you're trying to
see consciousness all the way down so
that would be where I would depart from
the pants
pants psychics and what would be worst
the folks beyond sort of raising
awareness of pantheism should have been
like raising awareness of how sort of
that God in the sky ideology of
structure society or duty should be sort
of writing new myths based on pantheism
or well where is it taking you Wow yeah
I think it's important to do both of
these things at the same time I think
it's important to do the critical work
of showing the damage that the God in
the sky has traditionally done and
that's very important and then at the
moment where I think a lot of us these
days are starting to say like alright no
forget it we're atheists at that point
to say but this doesn't mean we don't
get to have stories it doesn't mean we
don't get to have even sacred stories
and sacred myths and if you're
interested in doing that again start at
any any place around you start anywhere
around would use in the natural
technical world start with the way that
cameras work start with the way the
daffodils works all right and and kind
of go from there see what it is that
made that thing itself right what is it
what it what are the sets of materials
that go into making a camera a camera
what's the like the human labor what's
the animal labor what's the and the case
of the camera and you kind of start from
any object and see all the stuff that
goes into it then you'll see you'll
begin to see this sort of relational
multi aid gential process by which
anything becomes itself and then ask
yourself what it means to call that
whole set of productions itself a kind
of participation in divinity
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute's of
Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you